heute gibt's was zu gewinnen herzlich
willkommen zum zweiten Türchen des
Adventskalenders der Garten Youtuber das
ist eine ganz tolle Aktion unter den
Garten Youtubern um einfach mal Danke zu
sagen an euch dafür dass ihr immer
unsere Videos schaut dass ihr so liebe
Kommentare hinterlasst auch fürs
abonnieren Danke zu sagen und dafür dass
ihr einen Daumen nach oben gebt das
hilft uns Youtuber nämlich immer
ungemein und deswegen möchten wir euch
zur Weihnachtszeit einfach mal was
zurückgeben und dann machen ganz ganz
viele andere Kanäle mit die auch
gartenvideos machen also schaut auf
jeden Fall in die Videobeschreibung da
sind die ganzen anderen Kanäle verlinkt
und bei jedem gibt's auch was zu
gewinnen bei mir wird es drei Gewinner
geben und ihr könnt mitmachen indem ihr
unter das Video einen Kommentar schreibt
in dem ihr sagt welchen Gewinn ihr gerne
hättet und ähm jeder der drei Gewinner
bekommt auf jeden Fall Saatgut dass ich
selber aus meinem Garten gesammelt habe
da habe ich einmal seit gut von der
roten meldet das ist ein richtig
leckeres ja so ein salatartiges Gewächs
sieht wunderschön aus weil es eben kN
rot ist und schönes weinrot haben die
Blätter dann habe ich ähm riesen
hokkaidos angebaut und davon das Saat
gut aufgehoben und die Stangenbohne
Brunhilde gibt's auch noch zu gewinnen
das Saatgut bekommt also jeder von
meinen drei Gewinnern und dann gibt es
noch zweimal mein Buch Selbstversorgung
zu gewinnen das ist dieses Jahr
erschienen ist dank euch Platz 1 Spiegel
Bestseller geworden danke schön noch mal
an der stelle ich war extrem überwältigt
in meinem Buch geht es ganz viel um das
Thema Gemüse anbauen aber auch um
Hühnerhaltung und Brot backen um das
Verarbeiten der Ernte wir sprechen z.B
ganz viel übers fermentieren und über
das Einkochen über das Einlagern also
wenn ihr Lust habt das zu gewinnen dann
schreibt Buch unten in die Kommentare
das Gewinnen zwei von euch und einer von
euch hat auch die Chance mein
Gemüsegarten starten Online Kurs zu
gewinnen wir starten wieder mit einer
neuen Runde von Teilnehmern Anfang
Februar dann bekommt ihr also euren
Zugang und ja da geht es darum dass ich
euch ganz inten Brief an die Hand nehme
und durch das Gartenjahr begleitet so
dass wir deinen Garten in einen
wunderschönen üppigen Gemüsegarten
verwandeln der außerdem noch richtig
pflegeleicht ist also ich zeige da
Techniken mit denen man am Ende kaum
noch jäten und kaum noch gießen muss ja
wenn ihr darauf Lust habt dann schreibt
gerne Gemüsegarten starten unten in die
Kommentare und dann werde ich anfangen
Januar wenn die Adventskalender Aktion
vorbei ist drei von euch auswählen und
euch benachrichtigen und dann bekommt
ihr eure Gewinne zugeschickt yay ich
wünsche euch eine wunderschöne
Adventszeit schaut auf jeden Fall bei
den anderen Youtubern vorbei danke an
Max und danke fürs organisieren und dann
geht drauf und macht die Welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns im
nächsten Video wieder macht's gut
tschüss